[Music]
tonight Beauty and the Beast is seen the
light all right the movie blew away the
competition to finish number one at the
box office for a second week in a row
earning nearly 90 million dollars now
the movie is also almost made 700
million dollars worldwide in just those
two weeks insane numbers so we're
breaking down how Beauty became a
box-office beast
it's just feels like such an honor and
if my five-year-old self knew I was
gonna get to do this reason number one
this remake is such a hit Emma
delivered she's a major part of why fans
are flocking to see the film
we all remember her as Hermione from the
Harry Potter franchise but she's all
grown up now and an outspoken advocate
for women's rights making her the
perfect choice to play the Empowered I
[Music]
was already in reason number two the
nostalgia factor the 1991 original is
one of the most beloved movies in Disney
history and the first animated films to
earn an Oscar nomination for Best
Picture you might guess it's wonderful
this was a huge deal for me I mean I
watched it as a child you know ad
nauseam to the point where my parents
were like watch it again
another reason it's not just for kids
this movie has something for everyone
it is like full movies in one it's an
action movie it's also a comedy then on
the other hand it's a romantic drama and
then it's a musical finally reason
number four did we mention it's just
visually stunning memorable scenes like
be our guest took over a month to shoot
I love something that much you really
want to do it justice
[Music]
you